là messieurs bonsoir amandine n'est pour
l'instant qu'un prénom mais c'est déjà
la petite fille plus célèbre de france
ce soir 43 heures après sa naissance
vous savez presque tout d'elle 3 kg 4 51
centimes et et surtout son
extraordinaire conception dans une
éprouvette alors bien entendu cette
naissance a soulevé de considérables
espoir pour plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de femmes jusqu'alors stérile
désespoir qui convient de ne pas trop
encourager cette technique très
particulière est encore bien difficile à
mettre en oeuvre
martin à la réunion amandine est née de
la fécondation en éprouvette de
l'ovocyte de sa mère et de l'un des 500
me spermatozoïdes de son père que l'on a
réuni dans un tube pour donner un oeuf
qui furent est implanté avec succès
aujourd'hui antenne 2010 en direct de
clamart le professeur testard et bruno
lassalle les hauteurs de la méthode en
éprouvette ont reconstitué pour nous la
manipulation qui a été fait pour
permettre la naissance d'amandine tout
se passe à 37 degrés dans l'ombre comme
dans le ventre de la mère l'ovocyte est
recherché dans le liquide de prélèvement
il mesure à peine un dixième de
millimètre
il est paraît-il très visible à la loupe
puis il est placé dans une éprouvette
avec un liquide adéquat où il pourra
attendre quelques heures la rencontre
avec ses partenaires
pendant ce temps le sperme du père est
examinée et environ 500000
spermatozoïdes sont sélectionnés pour
leur mobilité et leur vitalité
quand tout sera prêt à l'aide d'une
pipette on réunira l'ovocyte et les
spermatozoïdes qui donneront l'oeuf
celui ci est incubé alors 64 eur il ce
segment en 2 4 8 16 cellules et c'est à
ce stade que devra se faire l'arrêt
implantation dans l'utérus maternel il y
a eu au début beaucoup d'échecs
mais aujourd'hui la technique est bien
au point
il semble que ce ne soit pas l'acte
biologique en éprouvette comme vous le
voyez là qui pose maintenant le plus de
problèmes mais c'est toujours la
réimplantation chez la mère
toutefois par ce procédé à ce jour dans
le monde plus de 100 grossesses sont en
cours dont deux en france et 16 enfants
sont nés dont deux jumeaux éprouvette en
australie dans notre pays on estime que
15 à 20 mille femmes stériles au moins
pourrait bénéficier de la méthode
c'est donc dans ce tube avec cette
manipulation aujourd'hui que peut se
jouer désormais l'avenir d'un être
humain
e